but we began this hour with a viral Tick
Tock video showing a racist attack on
the University of Kentucky's campus last
month now we warn you the video is
disturbing
[Music]
it shows that UK senior Sophia rosing
verbally attacking freshman student Kyla
Spring end appearing to physically
attack her as well spring was working
overnight at a dormitory front desk when
rosing entered the building without ID
she appeared to be drunk spring says she
asked if rosing was okay then she says
Rosie began hurling racist slurs kicking
punching and biting now roasting was
arrested by campus police and faces
multiple charges including assault and
public intoxication she is pleaded not
guilty the university has suspended her
and then permanently banned her from
campus the school President says in part
this Behavior was disgusting and
devastating to our community We Stand by
our students who were targeted by this
unacceptable hostility and violence
rosing's attorney told CBS News his
client will not comment at this time and
is currently enrolled in treatment he
says that rosing will apologize at the
appropriate time now in their first
interview and only on CBS mornings Kyla
spring and her mom her mother's name is
Betsy Jordan is here at the table
welcome to you both Carla a freshman
your first time away from home a
freshman student it's heartbreaking to
watch that video can you take us there
what you were thinking at the time while
this was happening to you
um I was thinking that I know the drill
I was raised to
act a certain way if I ever encounter a
racial attack or assault but I also was
very disheartened that it happened to me
while I was working and I really just
wanted to make sure I acted
appropriately so that I could keep my
job because the script could have been
flipped at any time if I had retaliated
because first you didn't think that she
lived in the dorm you really did one
wonder is she okay that was your first
thing and then she just started I
understand she used the n-word over 33
times it was told to me that it was used
over 200 times 200 times because there's
a 10 minute video and we only saw a
little part there and Betsy as her
mother at first you did not want her to
go public you didn't want any of us to
see that video why not
um
because I knew that it could go any way
how people respond to seeing the truth
that this is not an isolated incident is
this is something that happens it just
so happens to be on camera and I
honestly just struggled with what it
would look like and feel like to have
that disruption in our lives and it was
happening anyway and Kyla that this is
one time as a mom I actually had to
apologize to my daughter I said you know
what you're right you want to share this
that needs to be shared I apologize I'm
behind you I support you and whatever
you need and got to her as quickly as I
could Betsy what were you feeling the
moment you heard about what happened and
then saw the video afraid
I was afraid
um I was in Texas working away from home
anyway my daughter is in Kentucky on
campus and I knew that you know there
are rumors there's a lot shared about
racism in the South and what people how
people will respond there's um you know
there's been some ugliness that has
brewed in our country in the last few
years that makes you aware that racism
is still alive and I was just afraid of
what that would look like
to my daughter in 2022 you always hope
you're not going to be part of a story
like this Sophia rosing's attorney says
that she is kind of humiliated
embarrassed and remorseful by this
incident what do you say to that
I say that there is an opportunity for
growth in this situation
and I also say that this is an
opportunity for not just her to grow and
educate herself but people who might
have acted similarly or think similarly
to her
are you surprised you haven't heard
directly from her yet an apology I mean
I you know coming by the next day even
to find out how you are
um it hurts but I'm not surprised
you know there's another video in this
story not only of the attack but of a
march on campus in support of you where
you spoke it's a very powerful moment
you say that she will not break your
spirit and there's tears running down
your face we have a little clip of it
say my name is Kyla spring yeah yeah
um take us to that moment yeah take us
to that moment because what was coming
through your head at that point in your
heart it seems
but at that point I just felt so a part
of something bigger than myself
um I told myself I wasn't going to cry
you know I was on the Campus bus and I
was like okay I've written out what I
want to say I I know what I have to do
and then hearing like the rumble of
people young people my age that are just
like so fired up behind me and for this
cause on campus it was just like I
started crying and like I got a little
like weak in the knees and it's just
like it was such an amazing experience
to see so many people support supporting
Carla this hurts this hurts this is very
painful it's very painful to watch I
hope it's painful to people who are not
of color to know that you had to go
through that as a freshman how has it
changed you
I'm not even going to say has it changed
you I know I would assume that it has
changed how has it changed you it's
changed my outlook on how often the
situations like this happen obviously
I've seen things like this in the news
and I've heard about it
um but you never really know how common
of An Occurrence it is until it happens
to you
um so it was a little bit of a
um an eye-opening moment for me to like
wake up and really realize what's
happening in our country to
um young children of color to people of
color
um it's changed you you you seem like a
young woman with standards and integrity
and your mom raised you right you know
how to react or not react in that moment
and I'm not trying to encourage violence
at all but there are some people at home
maybe some black folks watching this
saying why turn the other cheek why do
we always got to take that High Roll you
have somebody yelling racist things that
you punching kicking and biting it might
be some people watching saying why
didn't you fight back
I would say to that person and those
people you can fight back and and but
not with violence
love is an appropriate way to fight back
respect honor and Grace is also fighting
back so it's not bowing down in a way
that it's weak it's bowing down in a way
that honors who you are and the truth
and integrity you're a character and who
God created you to be and so what I also
like about the fact that this happened
as terrible as it is is that this
actually occurs more often than a
violent response to racism and I
unfortunately there are not enough
videos of the right response happening
and so what I'm grateful for is that my
child has been girded in truth and honor
and Grace and integrity we're in a
moment where for more than 10 minutes
she was berated by someone who didn't
even have their right mind she was able
to remember who she was and to smile and
didn't even realize the magnitude of who
she was until after it had happened
because of what was already inside of
her certainly through the page out of
Michelle Obama's line when they go low
we go we go high but she didn't get that
way by herself Betsy no so Bravo to you
and Bravo to you Kyla that's a great
answer and we're grateful to both of you
for being here and for your Poise Betsy
spray and Kyla spring thank you very
much